[Music]
mede salto arguably the world's most
agile jumping robot his creators looked
all over the animal kingdom for
inspiration saltos legs bend like a bush
babies a small primate that appears to
have the greatest jumping agility of all
salto has a tail like the leaping agama
lizard to control direction the
designers even took a few tips from
humans and video game characters in real
life parkour and many virtual games
players run and bounce off walls to
propel themselves higher than their legs
ever put that saltos s trick hold the
wall jump first the robot crouches and
launches itself toward the wall
reorients mid leap and then jumps again
reaching a height greater than it could
with a single jump that initial Crouch
is what makes or breaks the jump saltos
Crouch is more like a super crunch the
robot stays low just long enough to
build up extra energy and uses it to
explode off the ground charging up
before launch is called power modulation
animals that can do it store the
built-up energy in their tendons salto
stores it in a spray in Bush babies this
makes their jumps 15 times more powerful
than if they use muscular action alone
but despite the researchers efforts
salto can best the Bush baby its jumps
are 22% less powerful than the public
creatures even still this is a giant
leap for robot kind
[Music]